bonjour à tous je suis belge de la
chaîne nota bene et aujourd'hui
j'aimerais vous présenter le troisième
épisode d'une série de programmes
dédiés à la propagande que j'ai
réalisé avec et l'ina institut
national de l'audiovisuel allez c'est
parti pour un épisode sur la propagande
barnes 68
diplomate de carrière
sur un autre terrain militaire de 32 go
bref le domaine universitaire de nantes
la faculté des lettres
une annexe de la faculté de droit
public jeunes gens et jeunes filles
habitant pour la plupart des recrues
viennent
18e arrondissement
la banlieue ouest il prend la fuite
un franco-ontarien les enfants
il doit appliquer univers
depuis novembre
grèves et manifestations
il ya un peu plus d'un mois
les membres de la toute fin des
résidents de la cité universitaire
c'est un projet de règlement intérieur
les députés déplorent même aucune
entrave ne lui prête plus d'attention
dans les pavillons des puits
les gens ont décidé ce soir l'arrivée
assis de l'autre côté de franchir la
barrière il s'est ensuite tenu de
l'équipement par les événements de
mai 68
ce point de départ ces revendications
premières semblent dérisoires
et pourtant le moment donné à l'ailé
embrasé la france entière les
influences de ce soulèvement sont à
chercher dans les lectures de ses
étudiants
mais aussi dans le combat dans lequel il
se reconnaissait comme le combat pour la
paix au vietnam et contre
l'impérialisme si à l'envers ça
à la lecture lorsqu'il a demandé à m
et bien évidemment un moteur puissant
de cette contestation qui est d'ailleurs
c'est pourquoi au-delà du cadre de
l'université il y arrive
différents groupements féminins
quand même il n'empêche c'est clair il
a en outre andré dieu merci
je pouvais faire
la nourriture
une révolution
pour vous c'est quoi changer de machine
les choses
q
aveyron
le ton monte à 42 68 hosni stable à
l'époque personne ne comprend ce soir
pas même le parti communiste la
puissante cgt
qui vend ses étudiants privilégiés
des bourgeois coupez les revendications
des travailleurs avant de les rejoindre
quelque temps plus tard
demel décision est prise par le doyen
de fermer le campus de longueuil
une décision qui finalement jacques
l'étudiante insurgés au coeur de la
capitale
ils sont rejoints par ceux de la
sorbonne elle aussi était en assemblée
générale permanente et j'avais fini de
se faire boucler le préfet grimaud on
voit alors les canaux et les crs mais la
répression n'est pas aussi ferme
qu'elle aurait pu l'être et ce pour une
raison toute simple ces jeunes sont
considérés par le pouvoir comme étant
la future élite de la nation et on ne
tire pas sur les journalistes les
professeurs les politiques les artistes
et les hauts fonctionnaires de demain la
contestation de son régime d'assemblée
générale permanente ne concerne pas
que paris nous souhaitons bien entendu
aux facultés de pro à
les étudiants à l'inversé leurs
collègues parisiens
aucun incident aujourd'hui à signaler
à dire
la journée a été calme comme le
montrent ces images et du coup de poing
des facultés mais dans les autres pays
on a discuté des récents événements
les dettes que la vuelta pas pour demain
le thème général des po en lisant
avec le syndicat national
l'enseignement supérieur
et pour parler de la télévision et de
la radio qui envahissent alors les
foyers français les étudiants ont
peint slogan la police semble par l'afp
tous les soirs inventeur
et en effet dans les journaux de l'autre
pièce
un visage revient régulièrement tout
au long du mois de mai absolu du préfet
grimaud celui qui a géré la crise et
auquel le gouvernement ne fournit que
très peu d'instruction un homme calme
et mesuré qui n'aura de cesse de faire
en sorte de ne pas activer les tensions
parce que nous avons eu de très
nombreuses manifestations partirai pas
tout le monde le sait les parisiens de
sable
efimova pélata nous sommes partis en
tolérant il est certain qu'on va pas
tenir le quartier latin avec la même
rigueur que l'échangé de fichiers ou
la place de la concorde il est
nécessaire que l'ordre soit plus
rigoureux le parti attend tolère très
facilement et de nombreuses
manifestations et tous les moyens mais
beaucoup selon rtl avec l'office de
radiodiffusion télévision française
alors sous contrôle des comptes ou sur
les reproches du gouvernement un
mauvaise presse auprès des insurgés on
lui reproche à raison de sa tanière
trois distances des événements
nous partirons rencontre
et quand elle le fait d'accorder une
place démesuré à la parole officielle
humour
oui mais voilà
l'homme
notons que beaucoup ont déclaré il ne
s'agit pas d'une poignée d'agitateurs
des responsables de l'ordre
nous avons eu avec une poignée de
prévenance de l'autre comme au premier
croyez-vous vraiment que vous pour
concourir au détour templeuve vendredi
aujourd'hui
mais je crois que m
la peau
elle exagérées
les manifestations le vendredi est
déporté
profondément des pouvoirs
profondément regrettable
elles sont donc plus qu'à voir comment
on peut avoir commis en manque là
lentement les manifestations qui se sont
déroulées à berne à marseille
rapport avec la romagne vienne voir
et même cracovie a pas plus tard que la
semaine dernière il est terrible
dans les journaux télévisés du 22 mai
14 mètres
sur 13 heures à 15 heures d'information
on parlera de vieux démons le taux de
retour
ils sont tous les deux ans
une heure trente sera accordée au
gouvernement
il est fondé de pouvoir
les informations de l'ouverture
réalisé par des journalistes aux
non-grévistes
des journaux comme on les appelle
accentus la propagande du côté du
pouvoir on s'inquiète à la renverse
du rôle joué par certaines radios dans
la flambée de la contestation
car même si il est avéré que le
discours officiel était majoritaire sur
les ondes le fait même d'accorder du
temps de parole obligatoire et donc du
crédit est perçu comme une
complaisance coupable c'est ce
qu'explique georges pompidou et alors
premier ministre au micro de france
inter
je le peux pas
l'ofsp a souligné le rôle
en pareil cas difficilement que les
tables
mais les farc
de radio
qui est sous-préfet et d'information
enflammée
un tel le provocateur
entre la diffusion du renseignement
et la complicité
entre le souci de recueillir les
explications des manifestants
et l'appel à la manifestation
il n'y a qu'un pas
et qui fut franchie
parfois allègre
ces radios c'est rtl et en europe 1 oui
le début à la fin de la révolte
l'accès à l'information et l'accès à
la parole publique est un enjeu crucial
car si les manifestants étudiants
finissent par être rejoints par une
foule travailleurs de tous les secteurs
et ceux d'une part tout en france on
sait que l'aspiration à plus de
liberté qu'il porte depuis nanterre on
rencontre un écho certain temps toutes
les couches de la population et compris
chez les journalistes dont le travail
est étroitement encadré
au point même que le rpf très touchée
par une série de mouvements sociaux
revendicatif
rappelant que les journalistes de
l'activité radiophonique réunis en
assemblée générale le 26 mai dernier
son prix acte de l'engagement solennelle
de toute la rédaction sans exclusive de
lutter pour obtenir un statut
démocratique de locataires au service
de la nation les journalistes de france
inter rappelle qu'en vertu d'une
décision de l'intersyndicale des
personnels de l'onu rpr ils sont garants
de la partie l information qui n'était
plus en mesure de garantir que la partie
habitée il userait de leur mandat et
demanderait à l'inversé amicale de
déclencher la grève il est vrai qu'à
l'époque le contrôle des médias par
le pouvoir étaient graves et que ce
succès dure montée de l'inquiétude et
la colère de la rue
mais aussi des rédactions de l'eau rtf
et des députés de l'opposition les
séances de l'assemblée nationale sont
pas là retransmises en direct
mais là aussi hors de question de
laisser aux télévisions une liberté
totale de retransmission dans un instant
le président de l'assemblée va
l'écart est de nouveau la séance
ouverte
je voudrais vous signaler que
de temps en temps vous entendez le son
en direct de l'assemblée nationale
autrefois celui-ci est coupée plat
dépens
du président de l'assemblée nationale
qui dispose des mêmes à la pyrrhus
top 100
sur son bureau ce qui explique que
quelquefois il appuie sur ce bouton le
capteur
donne-nous qui n'enlève leçon
autre tentative de censure et
d'interventions régulières du pouvoir
sur le travail des journalistes
la contestation est-elle dans les
rédactions qu'au sortir de la crise il
faut trouver un compromis et couper des
têtes
comme dans bien des révolutions
un certain nombre de médias personnels
et bien d'autre part d'intervenir à
l'ouverture
monsieur pierre de bois dette à quitter
ses fonctions
à la direction de la radio diffuse
monsieur émile biasini a remis sa
démission du directeur de la
télévision
qantas ne prévoit pas brillé il quitte
la direction de l'actualité télé
difficile de ne pas percevoir le
caractère révolutionnaire des
changements qui s'opèrent alors dans la
relation entre le pouvoir des médias
car mai 68 ce n'est pas seulement moi
agité c'est le début d'une nouvelle
phase de la modernité qui n'épargne
aucun secteur de la société lorsque
j'étais un peu plus tard mitterrand
entreprennent libéral mais les médias
radio et télévision
il s'agit une fois de plus d'une
tentative de réponse aux questions
primordiales opposées par le mouvement
de mai 68 au pouvoir en combattant dans
la rue
et au coeur de l'action
aujourd'hui encore se pose la question
de la proximité entre le pouvoir le
pouvoir économique et les médias
différemment ces artistes les acteurs
ont changé mais se pose toujours avec
d'autant plus de pertinence que internet
insurgés et que rien ne sera plus
jamais comme avant l'esprit de mai 68
saura-t-elle ressurgir dans les
rédactions donner à présent par les
grands et puissants patrons d'industrie
c'est en tout cas une des questions à
laquelle devra répondre ce début de
siècle une question à laquelle les
journalistes mme de gros apporter une
réponse pertinente ses filets on
espère que les pilotes vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à laisser vous retourne
dans les commentaires
et à vous abonner pour ne pas louper
les couches au pouvoir
quelle